[Musique]
si la fin de saison est particulièrement
chamboulé en raison du coronavirus les
rumeurs autour des nouveaux programmes
et du mercato font tout de même leur
apparition et plusieurs de ces rumeurs
concerne même directement cyril hanouna
en effet depuis plusieurs jours les
infos autour du retour de l'émission
culte à prendre ou à laisser sur ces
huit fait beaucoup parler et les
téléspectateurs se demande qui sera à la
tête de ce jeu de nombreuses rumeurs
indiquent que c'est cyril hanouna lui
même qui pourrait prendre les rênes du
jeu culte dans le même temps c'est une
autre info concernant cette fois-ci tpm
paix qui a circulé ces derniers jours
sur internet le cultissime supporters de
l'om rené malleville connu pour ses
coups de gueule mythiques comme gay ne
pas venir
les marseillais c'est eux comme quoi
c'est s'est parlé a annoncé sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il deviendrait la
saison prochaine chroniqueur récurrent
dans tpm paix une annonce à son image
ben voilà c'est confirmé ceux que ça
dérange ne venez pas me casser les
couilles le jeudi ne regardait pas et
tient bon un message auquel a répondu
baba hâte de te retrouver à la rentrée
tu vas nous faire mourir de rire à tes
pmp ce soir on vous donne plus de
détails sur toutes ces infos et donc on
va revenir déjà sur la deuxième info un
roi des mâles villemont rené d'amour que
j'aime qui nous rejoint à la rentrée un
tp je suis très heureux puisque rami
sera avec nous tous les jeudis rené et
rené je vais te dire pourquoi j'ai envie
que tu sois avec nous parce qu'un tel
personnage
2 je pense côté une vraie belle personne
et voilà et j'aime
voilà j'aime ce que tu véhicules et je
trouve que tu es voilà quelqu'un voilà
j'aime bien tu es un personnage était
quelqu'un qui est très attendrissant et
que j'aime énormément vrai je connais
pas personnellement puisqu'on sait je
crois qu on s'est revus qu'une fois de
visu je suis même pas sûr mais c'est
vrai que j'étais toujours rêver et
depuis que j'ai appris à le connaître
c'est vrai quoi là j'avais très envie de
travailler avec toi et renaît donc tu
nous rejoint dans tp bonne ou mauvaise
idée
rené qui nous rejoint franchement je
crois qu'ici tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que c'est mandy sera avec vous
je me dis franchement jean-michel toi
qu'est le plus ancien campement
moi je les adore c'est quelqu'un ça
personnage mais il est personnel jamais
dire les choses qui sait que ça va
choquer nous aidera pas si le ponte et
qui s'amarrent ses soucis nice on sait
pas que ces missions parisienne mais on
est tous on habite tous paris savoir
qu'à présent à l'action du sud qui parle
marseillais de l'importance de la ville
rose c'est génial comme un marseillais
parmi 6 alors rené moreu nez je suis
très heureux que tu sois avec nous et
c'est vrai que voir au démon plateau à
la rentrée septembre
je vous le dis
ça j'attends de le voir à côté
d'isabelle morini-bosc 500 candidats
rené on va voir les deux frères jumeaux
à côté ça fait du bien oui rené oui tu
étais heureux de nous rejoindre votre
sort tout le monde d'avoir évité et je
vais mettre certaines choses au point
par rapport à des cons qui est comme
critiquer tu vas chez hanouna les
supporters du psg
l'abordage a tutti le fric le fric alors
j'ai dit à tout le monde je rejoigne un
petit peu pas comme ce que disait
raymond par rapport à jean pierre
pernaut jaime perez père dont l'âge est
qu'il est là plus rien à prouver il a
raison de dire ce qu'il a dit et moi non
plus je sociétés creuzet hdtv qui m'a
demandé de venir je le fais avec grand
plaisir
je te dirais même mieux entre nous tu
peux reconnaître n'a plus jamais parlé
d'argent elle s'irrite 5e et jamais il
m'a même pas de modern et il m'a pas du
tout parlé d'un verre rien on en a même
pas pas il m'a dit oui ok c'est bon je
te jure que c'est vrai et voilà et je
voulais dire ce soir si tu peux me faire
un si jamais je dois toucher des sous je
sais pas si la grèce et que demain ce
que tu as à me donner le premier jeudi
où je vais chez toi et puis le donne aux
hôpitaux de phrases avec les ramener
avec lui dire rené scetbon mais je
l'adoré
il m'a pas trop longue une fois d'argent
rené bruneau qu'à me suis très très
heureux car valérie j'ai toujours dit si
à sa sainte et 13 ans je dois tam après
les larges un ou deux de radio star avec
qui je fais mon rêve à moi avec mes amis
que tu connais je les ai revus procès ou
de toi à sa 7 et razah sais que ma
vieille fait louper
voilà et donc aujourd'hui et bah tu veux
te faire plaisir et tu vas te faire
plaisir avec nous et je serais très très
heureux d'accueillir tous les jeudis
dans tpm paix à la rentrée ça cheuvreux
n'est pas ce que je t'aime énormément
est vraiment mal pourquoi les deux
choisi le jeudi ben je suis venu le dire
le jazz est monogame à moi
le vendredi le samedi et du match ya
l'om qui joue tiens voilà bravo mon rôle
et conan basterds moissonner gertie
d'avoir été là et on s'attend la rançon
aux temps forts on salue mon relais